you know the Russians can do anything they
want, the rehearsals that are
taking place today on the part of Russia and they
say that they were preparing for this and were
ready and
statements that supposedly we can deal with this issue,
I can give a very simple
answer Well, we would definitely be on that
we did not deal with the issue. We are not Korea,
and Russia is
right in that
recently in the world
,
none of the rules that existed until the beginning of
February this year are working, this is a very dangerous
thing, and when they attack
critical infrastructure objects, it is not
military  objects are objects on which
people's lives depend, the work of hospitals,
schools
of the elderly, life is like this,
you already know this is humanitarian terrorism, you
Kakhovsky,
it is mined, all the Arya units that are
there that produced
electricity are currently under the
control of Russian terrorists There
indeed, according to the data of our intelligence, there is a
huge amount of explosives, whether
they will use it or not. We have to
wait, etc  to react to their actions,
Britain is one of the countries that is in the
first place in terms of aid. I am no longer
sure what the next prime minister
will do. The same for our country as
Johnson and the highways did. So this will be a
continuation of this great help that the
people are doing  of Great Britain